by 2050 the world's population could
approach 10 billion and around 60% more
food could be needed to feed everyone
the environmental impacts of the food
system are daunting its responsible for
about a quarter of our greenhouse gas
emissions and uses about 70% of all
freshwater resources and it occupies
about 40% of the Earth's land surface
food rated emissions could increase to
50 percent by 2050 and fill up the total
emissions budget that we have in order
to avoid dangerous levels of climate
change interest in vegan food has been
booming across the rich world a major
study has put the diet to the test
analyzing an imagined scenario in which
the world goes vegan by 2050 if
everybody went vegan by 2050 we
estimated that food-related greenhouse
gas emissions could be reduced by 3/4
cows are the biggest emission
contributors bugs in their digestive
system produce methane and deforestation
for their pasture releases carbon
dioxide these gases warm the planet
if cows were a country they'd be the
third largest greenhouse gas emitter
I'm a ninth generation farmer in this
area I grew up on a farm with cows and
fattening bulls Yap cold leg comes from
a long line of farmers in the
Netherlands my goal is to be the biggest
butcher in the world we do it for meat
lovers but if you don't like me don't
buy our products but he's now a butcher
with a difference
I'm the vegetarian butcher
we are hooked on the taste of meat so
the only way to change it is to develop
products with the same experience
without an animal we can produce beef as
big as a front door with right texture
of real beef the equipment we used in
out plumber's plants is the same as in a
meat factory the only difference is
there was no blood on the floor
yep made the switch to plant-based meat
11 years ago he now ships to 17
countries with annual sales of 20
million euros the ingredients we use are
different we use soy we use Lupin we use
wheat we use peas we look to the meat
product we want to copy and look for the
right ingredients to get the same
experience farmed animals are land
hungry over 80% of the world's farmland
is used for animal production but it
produces only 18% of the world's
calories you need to feed a cow about 10
kilograms of mostly grains for it to
grow by one kilogram for pigs that's
about six kilogram and for chicken three
to four kilogram so a lot of food is
wasted as feed for four animals that we
would then eat growing animal feed means
more land per calorie of food is needed
to produce beef than broccoli two-thirds
of all agricultural land is used as
pastures and if you saved all those
pastures if people went vegan then that
would be the size of the continent of
Africa that would be freed and a
well-balanced vegan diets more varied
with less calories could save lives if
the world went vegan in 2050 we
estimated that premature mortality and
also all cause mortality could be
reduced by about 20% which could make
the global economy healthier too we know
how much money is used to treat certain
diseases that are associated with diets
coronary heart disease or stroke
cancer and diabetes then we get to an
estimate about one trillion US dollars
in 2050 that could be safe it would be
about three percent of all global
healthcare related costs but global meat
consumption is growing around the world
by almost three percent a year since
1960 nobody like the way we treat the
animals in factory farms nobody liked
the situation that is not good for our
health not good for the environment but
we all like meats very much
while yaks firm threatens meet farmers
meat companies and butchers our
customers and partners meat companies
don't own the farmers so it's easy to
change from chickens or pigs to
plant-based meat if the consumers wanted
and the market wanted they're happy to
change affordable and accessible
alternatives could yet see the rich
world hit peak meat and head down the
other side if we look at past trends
it's probably unlikely to assume that
the world would really go vegan by 2050
we found that without large-scale
dietary changes towards more plant-based
diets we would have a very slim chance
of staying below dangerous levels of
climate change but even moving towards a
plant-based diet could help according to
our estimates of predominantly
plant-based diet could get us probably
three-quarters of the way governments
can play a crucial role by setting the
right Dietary Guidelines they can adopt
procurement policies where it's clear
that standard foods that are ordered are
plant-based healthy and sustainable
for the vegetarian butcher plant-based
meat is just the next step in a long
history of developments in the farming
world it's always changing and
agriculture will hundred years ago there
were millions of draft horses to
transport to plug now they are
threatened with extinction because we
don't need workhorses anymore in the
future we will use machines to produce
our meat and the slaughter animals will
be threatened with extinction - and we
only had room for wild chicken and wild
pigs and that's the future I hope
[Music]